welcome back to CBS mornings many of the
toys bought as gifts this holiday season
can be connected to the internet through
Wi-Fi or Bluetooth and although they can
be educational or entertaining privacy
Advocates are concerned that too many
companies are collecting data on our
kids one study a few years ago found
that by the time a child turns 13 more
than 72 million data points have been
collected on them one family is telling
us about a toy they bought that had more
privacy implications than they realized
and they are sharing tips on what
parents should look out for in Connected
toys our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Warner has the story
can I have some colors New York mom
Katie taramiji bought what she thought
was a cool toy for her daughter Aubry a
couple Christmases ago something called
a fuzzable friend
I loved it Aubry now six especially
loved how the toy would connect with
Amazon's Alexa to communicate what the
fuzzable is supposed to do is you hit
the button
and it speaks in its own special
language then you ask
hey Alexa what did my father say and
Alexa says like she it wants to play
with toys or something so Alexa will
tell you what the fuzzable is actually
saying in our language it's the kind of
fun a connected toy can make possible
but buried in the terms and conditions
which her mom says she never read
creativity Inc the company whose
technology allowed the fuzzable to
connect to Alexa disclosed they collect
anonymized information about their users
and could generate transcripts of what
children were saying I don't like it at
all it's it's not it's not the correct
thing to do it's just one example of a
growing Trend say non-profit researchers
at the U.S public interest research
group or perg their recent report says
smart toys bring new risks including
microphones and cameras paired with
significant data collection perg's RJ
cross having any data collected on a
child that isn't strictly necessary is
really Reckless and unsafe because often
she says that data although anonymized
is sold to advertisers and she and other
experts say it can be used to create
profiles of children just like it can
for adults even educational Tech
products can have privacy risks when
Human Rights Watch analyzed 163
educational Computer Learning products
endorsed by 49 countries during the
pandemic 146 of them some 90 percent
were found to have put at risk or
directly violated children's privacy and
other rights for purposes unrelated to
their education the Electronic Privacy
Information Center or epic is calling on
the Federal Trade Commission to strictly
limit data collection on children it's
just a staggering amount of information
that's collected online information says
epic's executive director Alan Butler
that can be used to track kids Behavior
it's just not really realistic for our
parents as you say to be able to parse
these legal documents understand stand
what's happening technologically and
what's happening with their kids data
the FTC declined to comment Amazon told
us the third party fuzzable kids skill
is not currently available for Alexa
customers so Alexa cannot interact with
the fuzzable Friends toy the device is
not built by Amazon and does not have
Alexa built in tiramiji says she'll be
paying more attention to the fine print
from now on but doesn't think she should
have to I should be able to trust the
toy makers that are putting the toys on
the market you assume they're looking
out for your child's best needs and you
can't bury it in the fine print it makes
you not want to trust that company or
purchase from them again for CBS
mornings Anna Warner San Francisco
the manufacturer of fuzzable friends in
the company that provided the connection
to Alexa creativity Inc did not respond
to our requests for comments this
definitely makes me think because we're
having a kid of course have kids
technology is what parents lean on I
might go old school bring out the Etch A
Sketch as a gift or light bright or
anything that doesn't have a camera or
accessibility to the internet on it
because even my wife is not comfortable
with like
technology that like when you look at
your phone and face recognition she's
not cool with that but you're a rare
couple though most most people lean on
technology with their kids I mean I try
to do no screen time unless it's great
time
but it's scary because we know you know
the ticket to entry you know you're
going to be tracked with your phone a
smart watch but a toy is an innocent
thing and for a kid that's that's a
great story that is the terms and
conditions it's time consuming to read
but you have to read them